l'étape choisir la bonne citrouille
petites ou grandes ondes ou allongés
celle qui deviendra la plus effrayante
au coeur des marais de bourges une
quarantaine d'enfants participent à
l'activité
le programme de l'après midi est bien
chargé on va commencer au début par
couper le capuchon de la citrouille tous
après on va évident est la citrouille
avec les mains avec une petite avec une
petite ou une grande cuillère le couteau
c'est l'autre outil indispensable sous
la surveillance des parents chacun a sa
technique
en fait on fait un trou avec le couteau
là on découpe les bords après on prend
les graines qui on est dans un mec pour
les vider si on fait la pointe en bas il
a l'air méchant est allé pointer il a
l'air sympa donc maintenant il a trouvé
que c'était plus joli de faire l'appoint
temps toutes ces couches sont appelés
jack o'lantern une variété uniquement
décoratives impropre à la consommation
parfaite pour les décorations
d'halloween on a eu réfection de ce
projet au printemps donc moi j'ai mis en
culture 150 pieds de cours jacquot
lantern au mois de mai on a fait la
culture qui s'est déroulée normalement
malgré les deux canicule qu'on a pu
avoir et on a obtenu environ 200 fruits
qui aujourd'hui participent à cet
événement et à l'issue d'un après-midi
de créativité verdict et des paillettes
et j'ai mis de la mousse des triangles
pour les yeux l année et elle a une
bouche avec des dents à la tombée de la
nuit tous ces monstres orange prendront
vie pour devenir le soir d'halloween des
lanternes au visage effrayant